en medio de los escombros y bombardeos
un grupo de médicos en heart que ya ha
instalado una sala de parto improvisada
para asistir a mujeres ucranianas a dar
a luz en medio de la invasión rusa en el
momento en el que estás esperando
cualquier minuto para ver a tu hija a
quien has estado esperando durante tanto
tiempo incluso esas explosiones parecen
fuegos artificiales la directora del
centro perinatal regional de jarquín la
segunda ciudad más importante de ucrania
y una de las más atacadas desde el
inicio de la guerra cuenta que
convirtieron una habitación oscura del
sótano del hospital en una sala para
parto de cirugías hemos arreglado dos
lugares aquí pueden tener lugar dos
nacimientos al mismo tiempo no hemos
hecho esto en ucrania hace mucho tiempo
siempre hemos tenido salas de maternidad
individuales pero está claro que en esta
situación todos trabajamos bajo extremas
condiciones
los médicos permanecen el mayor tiempo
ahí por lo cual han llevado a sus
familiares e incluso a sus mascotas
además aseguran que cuentan con cuarto
de leche comida y todo lo necesario para
asistir a las futuras mamás
los talleres presentados el 99% nace
sano y sin problemas lo que me hace
feliz por supuesto los partos prematuros
ocurren esa es mi especialidad amamanta
moss bebés desde los 500 gramos tengo
cuatro de ellos en urgencias en este
momento
la organización children advirtió que
cerca de 6 millones de niños atrapados
en ucrania afrontan un peligro inminente
sin el juego